Roman Mars, when I say Konami code, does this mean anything to you? Ben Brock Johnson, it means zero to me, actually. I have no idea what you're talking about. I mean, when you say code, maybe I think of a cheat code. That's about it. That's all I got. You're getting warm. You're getting warm.
罗曼·马尔斯，当我说科乐美秘籍（Konami code）时，这对你来说有什么意义吗？本·布罗克·约翰逊，其实对我来说毫无意义。我完全不知道你在说。我是说，当你说秘籍时，我可能会想到作弊码。仅此而已。我就知道这么多。你快猜到了。你快猜到了。
We were mentioning all these kind of Easter eggs and cheat codes at the end of our first episode about NBA jam. And this is maybe the most famous, I would say, at least in some circles, so-called cheat code of all time. And it originated in a game called Gradius in 1986. So Gradius Roman is this spaceship shooter game, which I think both you and I enjoy. Totally. It was made by the Japanese entertainment company Konami. And Gradius, it had this code in it. The code would give you power-ups in the game, so like bigger guns, more shields, things like that, to help you fight the bad guys.
我们在第一集关于《NBA Jam》的结尾提到了所有这些彩蛋和作弊码。我可以说，这也许是所有“作弊码”中最著名的一个，至少在某些圈子里是这样。它起源于1986年的一款名为《宇宙巡航机》（Gradius）的游戏。罗曼，《宇宙巡航机》是一款太空射击游戏，我想你和我都挺喜欢的。完全没错。它是由日本娱乐公司科乐美（Konami）制作的。在《宇宙巡航机》中，就包含这个秘籍。这个秘籍可以在游戏中为你提供强化道具，比如更大的枪械、更多的护盾之类的，来帮助你对抗坏人。
To access this cheat code, there's a series of buttons and movements. And this code became a signature of Gradius, and it was so popular, it was copied into other games. So, for example, Roman, you might know this as the Contra code. Yes, that sounds more familiar. Yeah, that's a side-scrolling shooter, contra, right? Yeah, absolutely. And if you use this cheat code, you'd get 30 extra lives, which was important for Contra because Contra could be a hard game. Having 30 lives helps.
要使用这个作弊码，需要输入一连串的按键和动作。这个秘籍成了《宇宙巡航机》的标志，而且它非常受欢迎，以至于被复制到其他游戏中。例如，罗曼，你可能把它叫做《魂斗罗》（Contra）秘籍。是的，听起来更耳熟一些。对，那是一款横版卷轴射击游戏，对吧？是的，没毛病。如果你用了这个作弊码，就能获得30条额外生命，这对于《魂斗罗》来说很重要，因为《魂斗罗》可能是一款很难的游戏。拥有30条命很有帮助。
So this code is now so popular. It's also been reused, for instance, in Google Home. If you put this into Google Home, you'll get an interesting response. It's almost become its own kind of meme or reference. It's this wink from gamer to gamer that you both know this piece of video game lore. Okay. So if this cheat code is everywhere, like, Like, how do you access it?
所以这个秘籍现在非常受欢迎。它也被重新使用过，例如在Google Home中。如果你把这个输入到Google Home里，你会得到一个有趣的回复。它几乎成了它自己的一种模因（meme）或梗。这是玩家与玩家之间的一种默契，证明你们俩都知道这个电子游戏传说。好吧。所以，如果这个作弊码到处都是，比如，你到底该怎么使用它呢？
It is a series of moves on the controller, up, up, down, down, left, right, left, right, button or select, Roman, or B or A, depending on, you know, what controller you're using, what game. But the constant here, Roman, is the up, up, up, down, left, right, left, right, which admittedly sounds like gibberish when we say it out loud. but the difficulty of executing this particular cheat code really depends on the controller. It could definitely cramp your fingers on the Nintendo, but this code was so much easier for consoles that use an actual joystick. I could totally see it being easier on a joystick
它是手柄上的一系列动作：上、上、下、下、左、右、左、右，按键则是选择键（Select），罗曼，或者是B或A，取决于你用的是什么手柄，玩的是什么游戏。但这里的常数，罗曼，是上、上、下、下、左、右、左、右，我们大声说出来时，这承认听起来就像胡言乱语。但执行这个特定作弊码的难度在很大程度上取决于手柄。在任天堂（Nintendo）手柄上，它绝对能把你的手指按抽筋，但对于使用真正操纵杆的主机来说，这个秘籍要容易得多。我完全能想象在操纵杆上用会更容易。
because that's what a joystick is for is for going up and down. It's kind of the er controller. And a lot of things are designed around the joystick itself. That's right. There's so much that flows out of the joystick. joystick's development. And so that's what we're going to talk about today. This is Hidden Levels, our series about how the video game world has changed the world beyond video games. And today,
因为操纵杆的作用就是用来上下拨动的。它是一种更符合人体工程学的手柄。而且很多东西都是围绕着操纵杆本身设计的。没错。有太多东西都源于操纵杆的发展。所以这就是我们今天要聊的内容。这里是“隐藏关卡”（Hidden Levels），这是我们的系列节目，讲述电子游戏世界如何改变了电子游戏之外的世界。而今天，
we're going to find out how the joystick was created and why it has endured. Hidden Levels is our collaboration between 99% Invisible and Ben's podcast from WBUR, Endless Thread. And my Endless Thread co-host, Amory Seavertson, brings us this one. Enjoy. It was mid-December, 1903, on the northern coast of North Carolina. Two brothers, known at the time for a thriving bicycle business, were about to change the world. Orville and Wilbur Wright were about to go from peddling to piloting in engine-powered airplane. Now, I remember hearing about the Wright brothers in school, but what I did not know until recently is how they flew this thing.
我们将探寻操纵杆是如何被创造出来的，以及为什么它能经久不衰。Hidden Levels是由99% Invisible与本在WBUR的播客节目Endless Thread合作推出的。我的Endless Thread联合主持人埃默里·西弗森（Amory Seavertson）为我们带来了这期节目。请欣赏。那是1903年12月中旬，在北卡罗来纳州的北部海岸。两个当时以繁荣的自行车生意而闻名的兄弟，即将改变世界。奥维尔·莱特（Orville Wright）和威尔伯·莱特（Wilbur Wright）即将从踩脚踏板过渡到驾驶动力飞机。现在，我记得在学校里听过莱特兄弟的故事，但我直到最近才知道他们是怎么开这玩意的。
It was a full-body activity. Rather than sitting upright, the pilot was in a prone position. Wilbur Wright, we'll go with him since he made the longer flight. Sorry, Orville. Wilbur's hips were resting in something called the hip cradle, pieces of wood on either side that were connected to the tips of the wings of the plane with wire. So as Wilbur tilted his hips right and left,
这是一项全身运动。飞行员不是端坐着，而是呈俯卧姿势。威尔伯·莱特，我们就选他吧，因为他飞的时间更长。抱伏，奥维尔。威尔伯的臀部靠在一个叫臀部摇篮（hip cradle）的东西上，那是两侧的木块，通过电线与飞机的翼尖相连。所以当威尔伯向右和向左倾斜他的臀部时，
he was tilting the plane right and left. The up and down tilt of the plane was controlled by a lever in Wilbur's left hand, connected by a pulley system. This flight was an incredible feat, all 59 seconds of it. Yep, that's it. Because as the Wright brothers would be the first to tell you,
他就在让飞机向右和向左倾斜。飞机的上下倾斜由威尔伯左手边的一个杠杆控制，该杠杆通过滑轮系统连接。这次飞行是一个壮举，尽管只有短短的59秒。是的，就是这样。因为正如莱特兄弟最先会告诉你的是，
Their plane was really hard to control. They trained for months trying to get that hip-lean and lever tilt just right. But it was a little like patting your head and rubbing your stomach at the same time, except taking your life in your hands and hips. But just a few years later, in 1907, a French aviation pioneer, Robert Esno Peltri, suggested a new streamlined solution for bringing human and machine. together, a way to maneuver a plane up and down and right and left, with a single stick.
他们的飞机真的很难控制。他们训练了几个月，试图把那种臀部倾斜和杠杆倾斜掌握得恰到好处。但这有点像一手画圆一手画方，除了你要把自己的生命和臀部交给自己。但就在几年后的1907年，法国航空先驱罗贝尔·埃斯诺-佩尔特里（Robert Esno-Peltry）提出了一个精简的新方案，将人和机器结合在一起，一种用单杆操纵飞机上下、左右的方法。
All that mobility and control in the palm of one hand, almost like an extension of the self. As No Peltoree never experienced this for himself, but he did secure the patent for this new instrument, unaware that what he was patenting would end up in military planes and machinery, but also in arcades and homes around the world. I'm talking about the joystick. The origins of the term joystick are a bit murky. Some credit the British actor and aviator Robert Lorraine, who used it in a diary entry in 1910. Others claim the joystick was originally the Joyce stick, named for a different early 20th century aviator and inventor, James Henry Joyce of Missouri. One thing scholars largely do agree on, contrary to what you might read on the internet,
所有的机动性和控制权都掌握在一个手掌之中，几乎就像是自我的延伸。埃斯诺-佩尔特里从未亲自体验过这一点，但他确实为这个新发明申请了专利，并不知道他申请专利的东西最终会出现在军用飞机和机械中，也会出现在世界各地的街机和家庭中。我说的是操纵杆（joystick）。“joystick”这个词的起源有点模棱两可。一些人认为是英国演员兼飞行员罗贝尔·洛林（Robert Lorraine）最先使用的，他在1910年的一篇日记中使用了这个词。另一些人声称，操纵杆最初叫“Joyce stick”，是以20世纪初的另一位飞行员兼发明家、密苏里州的詹姆斯·亨利·乔伊斯（James Henry Joyce）命名的。学者们大体上同意的一点是，与你在网上读到的可能相反，
the joy in joystick does not have to do with its positioning between the legs of the pilot, like you might see in many World War I era planes. It's simply the exhilaration, the joy of taking flight. Now, most of us haven't personally taken flight, but we've likely controlled something with a joystick. I'm going to get it. I'm going to get it right by the head. Those claw arcade games where you try to grab onto a stuffed animal.
操纵杆（joystick）里的“joy”与它在飞行员双腿之间的位置无关，就像你在许多第一次世界大战时期的飞机上看到的那样。它纯粹是指飞行的兴奋和快乐（joy）。现在，我们大多数人都没有亲自飞上蓝天，但我们很可能用操纵杆控制过什么东西。我要抓到了。我要用夹子抓到了。就是那种抓毛绒玩具的街机抓娃娃机。
Maybe some sort of forklift or construction vehicle? Or most likely. I want this guy with a crazy blue hair. Ludwig. Ludwig. How do I select? A video game. The most important part is the joystick, so use that to steer.
也许某种叉车或工程车辆？或者最有可能的是。我要这个顶着疯狂蓝发的家伙。路德维希。路德维希。我怎么选择？电子游戏。最重要部分是操纵杆，所以用它来转向。
This is my friend Philip. Oh, top right is jump. My other friend Kelly. Hey, come on. Sorry. And my husband, Mike, all bearing with me. Oh, I feel like I'm enduring a lot of hits. In Baby's first game of Mario Kart.
这是我的朋友菲利普。哦，右上角是跳跃。我的另一个朋友凯莉。嘿，拜托。抱歉。还有我的丈夫迈克，都在迁就我。哦，我感觉自己承受了成吨的打击。在《马里奥赛车》人生第一局中。
I'm staying on the road. It's a miracle. Experienced players would agree. The joystick has made video game controller, what they are. Easy, precise, and fun. I finished. Hey, you've advanced.
我留在路上了。简直是奇迹。经验丰富的玩家会同意这一点。操纵杆成就了电子游戏手柄的现状。简单、精准而且有趣。我通关了。嘿，你晋级了。
You've advanced. And yet, it's only in recent decades that most of us have even had them within reach. In many ways, video games and joysticks and other controllers were moonlighting projects for a lot of engineers and early computer scientists.
你晋级了。然而，直到最近几十年，我们大多数人才真正将它们信手拈来。在许多方面，电子游戏、操纵杆和其他手柄对于许多工程师和早期计算机科学家来说都是兼职项目。
This is David O'Grady. He's a lecturer in design media arts at UCLA and a researcher in its game lab. And he told me that a lot of the first video games were developed in labs. But these ones were at institutions and companies known for working on technological developments for the military. You know, it was a way to kind of use your downtime to develop something other than some kind of military application or a missile tracking system. Or you might try to make a game just as a sideline kind of problem. One such engineer using his downtime to create a downtime activity was Ralph Bayer, the guy who invented the first home video game console, the Magnavox Odyssey in 1972. The electronic game of the future, Odyssey easily attaches to any brand TV black and white or color to create...
这是大卫·奥格雷迪（David O'Grady）。他是加州大学洛杉矶分校（UCLA）设计媒体艺术系的讲师，也是其游戏实验室的研究人员。他告诉我，许多最早的电子游戏都是在实验室里开发的。但这些实验室属于那些以从事军事技术开发而闻名的机构和公司。你知道，这是一种利用闲暇时间开发一些除军事应用或导弹追踪系统之外的东西的方法。或者你可能会尝试开发一款游戏，权当是一个副业性质的问题。有一位工程师利用闲暇时间创造了一项闲暇活动，他就是拉ルフ·贝尔（Ralph Baer），也就是1972年发明第一台家用游戏机Magnavox Odyssey（奥德赛）的人。未来的电子游戏——Odyssey，可以轻松连接到任何品牌的黑白或彩色电视机上，创造出……
The Odyssey's controls were knobs that you'd twist to do things like play a game of tennis. The horizontal knob on the left side of each player control unit allows you to move your player light in the left to right or right to left direction. The vertical knob on the right side of each player control unit lets you move your player light in an up and down direction. I don't know. This sounds a little like the right brothers, rocking their hips to move the plane one way,
Odyssey的控制器是旋钮，你可以转动它们来玩网球游戏之类的事情。每个玩家控制单元左侧的水平旋钮允许你向左到右或从右到左的方向移动你的玩家光标。每个玩家控制单元右侧的垂直旋钮允许你以上下方向移动你的玩家光标。我不清楚。这听起来有点像莱特兄弟，晃动他们的臀部来让飞机朝一个方向移动，
pulling a lever to move at another. Clunky. Takes them getting used to. But what if, just like an aviation, we streamlined the maneuvering, with a single, joyful stick. Ralph Baer did actually make a prototype of a video game joystick, but he wasn't the first to incorporate it into a game you'd see on shelves, David says.
拉动一个杠杆来让它朝另一个方向移动。笨重。需要时间去适应。但是，如果就像航空业一样，我们用一个快乐的单杆来精简操纵呢？大卫说，拉尔夫·贝尔确实制作了一个电子游戏操纵杆的原型，但他并不是第一个将它整合到你能在货架上看到的游戏中的人。
It would actually take until a little later in the 1970s for us to see commercially a device that we would call a joystick today. In fact, it was the Atari joystick, which is absolutely iconic. This little kind of squat black box with this stock on top of it and a single red button to the side, this is kind of the first moment where the joystick becomes, you know, not just a specialty piece of military hardware or something that airline pilots control when they fly, but something that all of us have access to. This accessible joystick came with the Atari VCS, or video computer. system, first released in 1977, and better known today as the Atari 2,600. Don't watch television tonight. Play it. Imagine what it must have been like as a kid back then, to have a game on your TV that you
实际上直到20世纪70年代稍晚的时候，我们才在商业上看到今天被称为操纵杆的设备。事实上，这就是雅达利操纵杆（Atari joystick），它绝对是个标志性产品。这个有点扁平的黑色盒子，上面有一个手柄，侧面有一个红色的按钮，这可以说是操纵杆第一次不仅仅成为军用硬件的特制品，或是航空公司飞行员飞行时控制的东西，而是成了我们所有人都能接触到的东西。这个触手可及的操纵杆随雅达利VCS（Video Computer System，视频计算机系统）一同问世，该系统于1977年首次发布，如今更为人所知的名字是雅达利2600。今晚别看电视了。玩它吧。想象一下，当年作为一个孩子，在电视上玩一款游戏会是什么感觉，
get to control using the same tool that's been used to fly planes. And yet, it's childishly simple to operate, almost no learning curve. Just power. and possibilities. So where does the joystick's power come from? What makes it so great? It starts with the term you hear a lot when talking joysticks with an expert like David O'Grady. An interface for flying is probably how we would describe it today.
你居然可以用曾用于驾驶飞机的同款工具来控制它。然而，它的操作却简单得像个孩子，几乎不需要学习曲线。只有力量和无限可能。那么操纵杆的力量从何而来？是什么让它如此伟大？这一切都始于你与大卫·奥格雷迪这样的专家谈论操纵杆时经常听到的一个词。飞行接口（An interface for flying）大概是我们今天对它的描述。
Interface, a point where two things meet, human and machine. And so a flight stick, a joystick, the kinds of controllers that we use today for video games and other applications, these are all an attempt to solve a fundamental issue, which is how do you provide human input to a device or a machine? In other words, what are the physical instruments that allow us to turn intention into action, that help make a machine feel like an extension of the self?
接口，即人与机器相遇的一个点。因此，飞行摇杆、操纵杆，以及我们今天用于电子游戏和其他应用的各种控制器，这些都是试图解决一个根本问题，即如何向设备或机器提供人类输入？换句话说，什么是物理仪器，能让我们将意图转化为行动，帮助机器感觉像是自我的延伸？
And what the joystick really has going for it? is this idea of affordance. What does the interface you're using enable, right? What does it allow you to do? For example, David says, our human biomechanics afford us the ability to walk, to move ourselves through space. A joystick affords us the ability
而操纵杆真正占优势的地方在于可供性（affordance）这个概念。你使用的接口能实现什么功能？它允许你做什么？例如，大卫说，我们人类的生物力学赋予了我们行走的能力，让我们能够在空间中移动自己。操纵杆赋予了我们
to move something else through space without really having to think about it. Exactly. I think that's such an important part of interface design from joysticks to mice to everything else, that in some ways it is a kind of invisible art. For most applications, we want the interface to disappear. We want to look at where we're pointing,
在空间中移动其他东西的能力，而甚至不需要去思考它。没错。我认为这是从操纵杆到鼠标再到其他所有接口设计中非常重要的一部分，在某种程度上，它是一种隐形艺术。对于大多数应用，我们希望接口消失。我们希望看着我们指向的地方，
not at the hand that's doing the pointing, right? You want it to feel like mind control. Like we're just controlling things with our mind without having to. Yeah, exactly. There's something very automatic about it, right? What David's getting at here is really a number. another meaning of affordance. It's not just about what an interface allows us to do.
而不是看着那个正在进行指向的手，对吧？你希望它感觉像意念控制。就像我们只是用大脑控制事物而不需要去。是的，完全如此。这里面有一种非常自动化的感觉，对吧？大卫在这里要表达的实际上是可供性的另一个含义。
It's knowing how to do it, intuitively. There's a kind of direct manipulation quality to it. Do you want to move forward on a screen? Press the stick forward. Do you want to move backwards within the environment of the screen? Pull the stick backwards. Do you want to go left? The joystick has what's called perceived affordance.
这不仅关于接口允许我们做什么。它是关于直观地知道该怎么做。它带有一种直接操纵的品质。你想在屏幕上向前移动？把摇杆向前推。你想在屏幕的环境中向后移动？把摇杆向后拉。你想向左？操纵杆具有所谓的感知可供性（perceived affordance）。
You see one and you know exactly how to. to use it. Compare that to those knobs on the Magnavox Odyssey. Sure, you can imagine that you should probably twist them, but what does that motion have to do with moving through space? Now, with a joystick... The motion of your hand and arm deeply corresponds with what's happening on screen. You don't really need to read an instruction manual to do that. This was just the pep talk I needed before taking a few. field trip to a joystick wonderland. So everything's usable, but it does go chronological.
你看到一个，就知道该如何使用它。把它与Magnavox Odyssey上的那些旋钮相比。当然，你可以想象你应该转动它们，但这种动作与在空间中移动有什么关系呢？现在，有了操纵杆……你的手和手臂的动作与屏幕上发生的事情深度契合。你根本不需要阅读说明书就能做到这一点。这正是我在进行几次实地考察前往操纵杆奇幻乐园之前所需要的鼓励。所以一切都可以用，但它是按年代顺序排列的。
Jeff Boojack is the owner of Prodigy, an 8,000 square foot game room in Western Massachusetts with a glow-in-the-dark mini golf course in the center, hell yeah, and a perimeter of more than 6,000 retro video games and their consoles dating back to the late 70s. It's pretty much just my collection. I'm an organized hoarder. Jeff has all matter of retro video game accessories, too. The Nintendo Power Glove, a short-lived, ill-performing motion control device that made you look like a space movie badass from the forearm down. Jeff's got it.
杰夫·布贾克（Jeff Boojack）是马萨诸塞州西部一家名为Prodigy的8000平方英尺游戏厅的老板，那里中心有一个夜光迷你高尔夫球场，太棒了，周围摆满了6000多款可以追溯到70年代末的复古电子游戏及其主机。这基本上就是我的收藏。我是一个有组织的囤积狂。杰夫也有各种各样的复古电子游戏配件。任天堂Power Glove，这是一款寿命短暂、表现糟糕的动作控制设备，从前臂往下看，它让你看起来像个太空电影里的硬汉。杰夫有这个。
This was horrible, because for every game you had to put it into different code. The Logitech NetPlay, basically a full-sized keyboard scooched between two halves of a modern-ish game controller. Jeff has that, too. This was the, hey, let's just combine everything, because computers, at this point, we're starting to really take off. This was like... But most importantly, Jeff has the Atari 2,600. I mean, this is a beast.
这太糟糕了，因为每个游戏你都得输入不同的代码。Logitech NetPlay，基本上就是一个全尺寸键盘，塞在两个半现代游戏手柄中间。杰夫也有这个。这就是那种“嘿，让我们把所有东西结合起来吧”的产品，因为电脑在当时开始真正腾飞了。这就像……但最重要的是，杰夫拥有雅达利2600。我的意思是，这是一个庞然大物。
This was probably the best built controller. I'd driven two hours to see one of these nearly 50-year-old home consoles in person. And? They're boring looking. Oh, yeah. I mean, they're... I'm sure they were very exciting for the time, but yeah, this looks like this could be your your grandpa's radio or something.
这可能是制造得最好的控制器。我开了两个小时的车来亲眼看看这些将近50岁的高龄家用主机之一。然后呢？它们看起来很无聊。哦，是的。我是说，它们……我确信它们在当时非常令人兴奋，但是的，这看起来就像是你爷爷的收音机什么的。
Exactly, yeah. It's just black and brown and nothing that says, like, spend a lot of time with me. But Jeff kindly fired it up for me. And then, of course, you have to turn it down, that's incredibly wild. So I could experience the Atari joystick for myself in a game of Pac-Man.
没错，是的。它只是黑色和棕色的，没有什么让人觉得“花大把时间陪我吧”的东西。但杰夫好心地为我启动了它。然后，当然，你必须把音量调小，这真是太疯狂了。所以我可以在《吃豆人》游戏中亲自体验雅达利操纵杆。
And then you just move a joystick. That's it. What's the button for then? Nothing. This game has... With a little square joystick panel stick, steadied on my lap with my left hand, and my right fist, white-knuckling the joystick. I jolt it right, left, forward, back, trying to gobble up as many little Pac-Man pellets as I can, until...
然后你只需移动操纵杆。就这样。那按钮是干什么用的？什么都不干。这个游戏有……左手把着正方形的小操纵杆面板放在膝盖上，右手握拳，死死地攥住操纵杆。我把它向右、向左、向前、向后猛推，试图尽可能多地吞掉那些吃豆人小圆点，直到……
You're being thrown right in. I'm supposed to avoid the ghosts. Okay. Yep, yeah, we're supposed to get the small pellets. I meet a demise so swift, I think even Jeff is surprised. But I try again, and pretty quickly, I realized something that he'd actually warned me about with the Atari joystick. Oh, it is rigid.
你直接被扔进去了。我应该避开幽灵。好的。是的，没错，我们应该去吃小圆点。我遭遇了一场极为迅速的惨败，我想连杰夫都感到惊讶。但我再试了一次，很快我就意识到了一点，其实他之前就警告过我关于雅达利操纵杆的问题。哦，它好硬。
I'm having a hard, like, it's not as responsive as I thought it would be. Nope. No. This iconic device sucks. It's stiff to the point where it hurts my wrist minutes into the game. Could you imagine hours? No. But back when the Atari joystick was a novel thing in the late 70s, people did spend hours with it.
我感觉有点吃力，它没有我想象的那么灵敏。不。没有。这个标志性的设备太烂了。它僵硬到游戏开始几分钟就让我的手腕感到疼痛。你能想象几个小时吗？不能。但早在70年代末雅达利操纵杆是个新鲜事物时，人们确实会在它上面花上几个小时。
Pac-Man, Space Invaders, Adventure. you could play 1,300 different game variations with this one joystick console. Have you played Defender? It's the newest of the smash-at-home video games that just keep coming. Before people had home computers or the internet, or even just a wider variety of TV channels, this was the epitome of joy. This is all you did. I mean, I'm sure when a family got, this, kids were playing with these joysticks for seven, eight hours
《吃豆人》、《太空侵略者》、《冒险》。你可以用这个单一的操纵杆主机玩1300种不同的游戏变体。你玩过《保卫者》（Defender）吗？这是不断推出的最新热门家用电子游戏之一。在人们拥有家用电脑、互联网，甚至只是更丰富的电视频道之前，这就是快乐的巅峰。这就是你所做的一切。我的意思是，我确信当一个家庭得到这个时，孩子们会连续七、八个小时玩这些操纵杆，他们的手和手腕肯定会承受巨大的疲劳，可以说是巨大的疲劳。我可能只能玩十分钟左右。而这就是这个设备发挥作用的地方。杰夫所说的“这个”指的是他现在手里拿着的完全不同的手柄。
at a time, their hands and wrists must have gotten massive fatigue, like massive fatigue. I can only play these for maybe ten minutes. And that's where this frees that up. By this, Jeff means an entirely different controller he's now holding.
这就是你面前的任天堂64？是的。这就是那个长着三个小突起，你要握住外面两个突起的手柄。然后只有一个突起，也就是手柄，这么说吧。是的，说来尴尬，任天堂64手柄上有三个。它的形状有点像一个倒三叉戟。告别那些无聊的方块状设备吧，这个于1996年问世的手柄看起来就像一艘小飞船。
This is the Nintendo 64 that you have in front of you? Yep. This is the one with the like the three little prongs and you hold on to the two outer prongs. Then there's just the one prongs, the handles, let's say. And yes, awkwardly enough, there are three of them on the Nintendo 64 controller. It shaped kind of like an upside-down trident. Out with the boring block-like devices, this controller, which came out in 1996, looked like a little spaceship.
位于中间手柄上的是一个白色的突起，大约半英寸高。这就是任天堂击中要害的地方。他们在那个时候让电子游戏变得极具吸引力。击中要害？更像是把大拇指放在摇杆上。这是一种新型的操纵杆——拇指摇杆（thumb stick），专为以操纵杆的直观性、但又具有更大移动便利性来导航电子游戏而设计。
And positioned on the middle handle is a whitish protrusion, maybe half an inch high. That's where Nintendo was like, they really hit the nail in the head with that. They made video games extremely addicting at that point. The nail on the head? More like the thumb on the stick. This was a new kind of joystick, a thumb stick, made for navigating a video game with the intuitiveness of a joystick, but with much greater ease of movement.
不再有僵硬的手腕，只有流畅的拇指画圆。然后你会觉得，哦，好吧，我现在可以玩12小时了。在这个时期发生改变的不仅仅是接口。游戏也在变。随着电子游戏主机微处理功能增强，游戏世界能够从二维（其中角色的移动基本上只限于上下或左右）走向三维。你可能还记得从高中代数或其他地方学过的内容，
No more stiff wrists, just smooth thumb circles. And then you're like, oh, okay, I can play for 12 hours now. It wasn't just the interface that was changing around this time. The games were, too. As the micro-processing power of video game consoles increased, game worlds were able to go from two dimensions, where the characters really only went up and down or right and left, to three. You might remember from, I don't know, high school algebra or something,
X轴代表左右，Y轴代表上下。好吧，现在我们来到了朝向你和远离你的Z轴。再次请出大卫·奥格雷迪，我们来自加州大学洛杉矶分校的游戏学者。我们在20世纪90年代开始涌现出整类游戏，它们使用了一种类似第一人称的视角。事实上，我们仍然将其称为第一人称射击游戏。它们在普及三维空间游戏方式方面发挥了巨大作用，基本上，像《黄金眼007》（GoldenEye 007）这样的游戏，
the X-axis left and right, the Y-axis up and down. Well, now we're on a Z-axis moving towards you and away from you. David O'Grady again, our game scholar from UCLA. We had whole genres of games that were starting to emerge in the 1990s that used a kind of first-person point of view. In fact, we kind of know them still as first-person shooters. We're huge in popularizing a way of playing in 3-D space, essentially. Games like GoldenEye-O-O-7,
它允许玩家穿梭于错综复杂的迷宫、爬上梯子、穿过桥梁。这些游戏的视角使你基本上成为了摄像机，因此你在屏幕上看不到多少你自己的化身或你正在玩的角色的形象。除了你拿着枪的手之外，在这个例子中。它基本上就是你。而你身临其境，向右、向左、向上、向下，深深沉浸在虚拟现实中。
which allowed a player to weave through conquering, Creep mazes, up ladders, across bridges. These games have a point of view where you are the camera, essentially, and so you don't really see much of an avatar of yourself on screen or of the character you're playing. Other than your gun-toating hand, in this case. It pretty much is you. And you are immersed, going right, left, up, down, and deep in virtual reality.
所以，我们把操纵杆的天才设计直接握在了大拇指尖。我们具备了在具有视觉深度的游戏中穿行的能力，直到我们撞上一堵墙，字面意义上的墙。因为仅凭一个控制移动的拇指摇杆，我们没有一种简单的方法先去环顾我们正要去的地方。因此大卫说，现在我们需要将移动与观察分离。这是两件基本的事情。
So, we have the genius of the joystick right at our thumbtips. We have the ability to move through games with visual depth until we hit a wall, literally. Because with just one thumbstick that controls movement, we don't have an easy way to look where we're going first. So now, David says, we need to separate out movement from looking. These are two fundamental things. things that we tend to do in our lives and also in games which tend to simulate things that come from our lived experience. In real life, we don't have to move in a particular direction whenever we look that way. Like, now I'm looking over here, here I come, now I'm looking
我们在生活中以及在游戏中往往会做这些事，游戏往往模拟了我们生活经验中的体验。在现实中，每当我们看向那个方向时，我们并不一定非要朝那个特定方向移动。就像，现在我看向这边，我来了，现在我看向这边，我来了。而且我们可以在朝一个方向看的同时向另一个方向移动。现在并不是说你不能在N64手柄上进行独特的观察和移动，或者平移，但这很不优雅，需要更多的按键，具体来说是十字键（D-pad或directional pad），那个上下左右呈十字形键，它就是没有拇指摇杆那么容易或精确。所以呢？
over here, here I come. And we can move in one direction while looking in another. Now it's not that you couldn't look and move distinctly, or strafe on the N64 controller, but it was inelegant, involved more buttons, specifically the D-pad or directional pad, the up-down, left-right, cross-shaped one, which just isn't as easy or precise as the thumbstick. And so? The long and short of it is we came up with a two-thumb solution, two analog thumb sticks that sit underneath each of your thumbs. Analog, meaning you are controlling the degree of motion with how hard you press the thumbstick in a particular direction,
简而言之，我们想出了一个双拇指解决方案——两个放在你每个大拇指之下的模拟拇指摇杆。模拟（Analog）意味着你通过用力将拇指摇杆按向特定方向来控制运动的程度，
and two joysticks to physically separate the looking from the going. The right thumbstick typically is sort of pointing the way to go, and the left thumbstick is actually doing it. It's the movement. Basically, one joystick is your eyes, the other, your legs. The pioneer of this two-thumb solution, Sony PlayStation's dual thumbstick controller, which came out a year after the Nintendo 64 in 1997, with, yes, two thumbsticks symmetrically positioned,
并用两个操纵杆从物理上将观察与移动分离。右侧的拇指摇杆通常指引前进的方向，而左侧的拇指摇杆实际上在执行它。它负责移动。基本上，一个操纵杆是你的眼睛，另一个是你的双腿。这种双拇指解决方案的先驱是索尼PlayStation的双摇杆手柄，它在任天堂64问世一年后的1997年推出，带有是的，两个对称放置的拇指摇杆，
that afforded you the ability to move very precisely and aim very accurately. Like in Medal of Honor, a World War II combat game, created by Steven Spielberg, and inspired by his then-recent film Saving Private Ryan, and, according to a couple of his collaborators, by watching his son play Golden Eye-O-7. It was among the first games to really integrate both thumbsticks into its gameplay. With a second thumbstick, it was easier than ever to make your on-screen avatar do exactly what you wanted it to. as close to mind control as a controller could get. The gaming industry had reached peak interface,
这赋予了你非常精确地移动和非常准确地瞄准的能力。就像在《荣誉勋章》（Medal of Honor）中一样，这是一款由史蒂芬·斯皮尔伯格（Steven Spielberg）创作的二战战斗游戏，灵感来自于他当时刚上映的电影《拯救大兵瑞恩》（Saving Private Ryan），据他的几位合作者说，灵感还来自于看他的儿子玩《黄金眼007》。它是最早将两个拇指摇杆真正融入游戏玩法的游戏之一。有了第二个拇指摇杆，让屏幕上的化身完全按照你的意愿行事比以往任何时候都更容易。这堪称手柄所能达到的最接近意念控制的水平。游戏行业已经达到了接口的巅峰，
and the proof is in the play. Because while the video game industry has continued to iterate on the design, Xbox moved the thumbsticks diagonally. The tactile experience has become increasingly buttery, as I felt for myself in Jeff Boojack's game room. Oh, these thumbsticks are very joyful, very smooth. The dual stick controller itself hasn't changed all that much, functionally or stylistically, in the nearly 30 years that we've been using it now to navigate 3D space.
而证据就在游戏中。因为虽然游戏行业一直在对设计进行迭代（Xbox将拇指摇杆改为了对角线排列），但触觉体验变得越来越丝滑，就像我在杰夫·布贾克的游戏室里亲身体验到的那样。哦，这些拇指摇杆太带劲了，非常顺滑。在近30年的时间里，我们一直用它来导航三维空间，而双摇杆手柄本身在功能和风格上并没有发生太大的变化。
What has changed in that time are the spaces we're using it to navigate. If it ain't broke, don't fix it. In fact, just throw it to your troops. Coming up, video game thumbsticks go from game world battlefields to real ones. You know, Within a century, we've gone from using a joystick to navigate three-dimensional airspace to using it to move Pac-Man two-dimensionally, up, down, left, right, on screen, to shrinking it beneath our thumbs, to adding a thumbstick to make maneuvering through a game world feel like moving through the real world. And where we've arrived now, at the modern dual-stick
在这段时间里改变的是我们用它来导航的空间。如果没有坏，就不要去修它。事实上，直接把它扔给你的部队吧。接下来，游戏拇指摇杆从游戏世界的战场走向了真实战场。你知道，在不到一个世纪的时间里，我们已经从使用操纵杆在三维空域中导航，到用它在屏幕上二维地移动《吃豆人》（上下左右），再到把它缩小到我们的大拇指之下，再到添加一个拇指摇杆，让穿梭于游戏世界的感觉就像在现实世界中移动一样。而我们现在所到达的地方——现代双摇杆
video game controller is a new period of evolution, not of the interface itself, but in what we're using it for. What makes, in your mind, a video game controller the right tool for operating the kinds of advanced weapons that the military is using it for? It's generally a matter of familiarity. Jared Keller is a long time. military technology journalist. He wrote a piece for Wired Magazine last year called
游戏手柄，标志着一个新的进化时期，不是接口本身的进化，而是我们用它来做什么。在你看来，是什么让游戏手柄成为操作军方正在使用的那种先进武器的正确工具？这通常是一个熟悉度的问题。贾里德·凯勒（Jared Keller）是一位资深的军事科技记者。他去年为《连线》杂志（Wired Magazine）写了一篇文章，题为
This Video Game Controller has become the U.S. military's weapon of choice. The controller he's talking about is the Freedom of Movement Control Unit, or FMCU. It's rugged, it's designed to be durable and to endure intense environments, but to the average observer, it would look like anything that comes with a PlayStation or Xbox. Yeah, it's like shaped like a PlayStation or Xbox controller, but it's like tan in color, you know, kind of your stereotypical military color palette. Yes, coyote tan is what they call it.
《这款游戏手柄已成为美军的首选武器》。他谈到的手柄是机动自由控制单元（Freedom of Movement Control Unit，简称FMCU）。它很坚固，旨在经久耐用并承受恶劣的环境，但对于普通观察者来说，它看起来和PlayStation或Xbox附带的任何东西没什么两样。是的，它的形状就像一个PlayStation或Xbox手柄，但它是土黄色的，你知道，有点像是你们刻板印象中的军事配色方案。是的，他们称之为郊狼棕（coyote tan）。
Coyote tan, okay. Yeah, or sometimes, you know, desert tan, right? Right. But really, I cannot stress enough that if these FMCU controllers weren't desert tan, you really would just think they were for Fortnite or Final Fantasy. They have the two thumbsticks, the D-pad, the all-too-familiar trigger buttons on the tops of the handles, except in this case, they are actual triggers. The military has been experimenting with video game controllers for the last two decades, but their proliferation and use has really accelerated in recent years as their utility has been demonstrated in various field experiments and tests. The Pentagon has confirmed the use of the FMCU controller in the recent years.
郊狼棕，好吧。是的，或者有时，你知道，沙漠黄，对吧？对的。但真的，我怎么强调都不为过，如果这些FMCU手柄不是沙漠黄的，你真的会以为它们只是用来玩《堡垒之夜》或《最终幻想》的。它们有两个拇指摇杆、十字键、手柄顶部那些极其熟悉的扳机键，只不过在这个案例中，它们是真正的扳机。美军在过去二十年里一直在试验游戏手柄，但随着其效用在各种实地实验和测试中得到证实，它们的普及和使用在近年来真正加速了。五角大楼已经证实近年来使用了FMCU手柄。
the Air Force's Radbo, or recovery of air bases denied by ordinance vehicle, a boxy, desert tan bomb-finding truck. Also in the Army's short-range air defense system, picture heavy-duty vehicles, often unmanned, with turrets and machine guns and missile launchers mounted on top to take out low-flying threats like helicopters and small planes. Every mission is different, the FMCU's product description reads, shouldn't your controller be as versatile as you are? The FMCU isn't the only game controller that's in the action, Jared says. The Army's locust laser weapon system blasts drones out of the sky using an actual Xbox controller. It gives the operator a better sense of control and focus on a system that requires precision to
空军的Radbo（由弹药拒绝的空军基地回收车辆，Recovery of air bases denied by ordinance vehicle），一辆方头方脑的沙漠黄寻弹卡车。还有陆军的短程防空系统，想象一下那些重型车辆，通常是无人驾驶的，顶部装有炮塔、机枪和导弹发射器，用于消灭直升机和小型飞机等低空飞行的威胁。每个任务都不同，FMCU的产品描述中写道，难道你的控制器不应该和你一样多才多艺吗？贾里德说，FMCU并不是唯一参与行动的游戏手柄。陆军的“蝗虫”激光武器系统（Locust laser weapon system）使用真正的Xbox控制器将无人机从空中击落。它使操作员对需要精密度的系统有更好的控制感和专注度，从而
effective. And the U.S. military isn't the only one using video game controllers. The British Army, the Israel Defense Forces, also the armed forces of Ukraine, who, Jared says, have been using PlayStation controllers to direct armed drones and machine gun turrets at invading Russian forces. So, why? Why video game controllers? One reason, as you heard, is for familiarity. Gen Z and Gen Alpha, who are going to make up the majority of the armed forces in the coming decades, have grown up on these systems. So why waste time building a new one when you can give prospective troops something they're already familiar with and can use almost instantaneously? Another, that precision Jared was talking about, the mobility of the
发挥效果。而且美军并不是唯一使用游戏手柄的军队。英国陆军、以色列国防军，还有乌克兰武装部队，贾里德说，他们一直在使用PlayStation手柄来指挥武装无人机和机枪炮塔攻击入侵的俄军。那么，为什么？为什么是游戏手柄？正如你所听到的，原因之一是熟悉度。在未来几十年里将构成武装力量主力军的Z世代和Alpha世代就是在这些系统上长大的。所以，当你可以给未来的部队提供他们已经熟悉且几乎可以立即使用的东西时，为什么要浪费时间去造一个新的呢？另一个原因是贾里德之前谈到的精确度，
thumbsticks for directing vehicles and weaponry, and the level of responsiveness that, According to the FMCU's product description, can, quote, be the difference between success and failure. But also, the military doesn't have to reinvent the controller. In fact, Jared says that might be for the best. I think we've all heard the joke that a camel is a horse designed by committee. I have not heard that joke. Yeah, but often, you know, a lot of proprietary systems designed by the
用于指挥车辆和武器的拇指摇杆的机动性，以及响应水平，根据FMCU的产品描述，这可以“成为成功与失败的区别”。但同时，军方也不必重新发明手柄。事实上，贾里德说这可能是最好的选择。我想我们都听过那个笑话，骆驼是由委员会设计出来的马。我没听过这个笑话。是的，但通常情况下，你知道，许多由国防部（DoD）设计的专利系统最终都变成了骆驼，这不一定是因为糟糕的设计决策，而是因为知识、理解和研究已经存在于私营部门中。不仅它已经存在，贾里德说，它很可能已经被完美打造出来了。正如技术专家彼得·辛格（Peter Singer）多年前所说的那样，游戏公司花了大笔资金来开发最优、最直观且易于学习的东西。而军方基本上是在说，好吧，他们替我们完成了这项工作。让我们建造这些系统，以便下一代作战人员能够将这些技能无缝地适应到军事语境中。
the DoD end up being camels, not necessarily because of, you know, bad design decisions, but because the knowledge and understanding and research exists out there in the private sector. Not only does it already exist, Jared says, it may very well have already been perfected. The gaming companies, as the technologist Peter Singer put it years ago, spent tons of money developing what is optimal, intuitive, and easy to learn. And the military is basically saying, well, they did the job for us. Let's build these systems so that this next generation of war fighters can adapt those skills seamlessly to a military context.
游戏公司替他们完成了工作。现在，具体谈到操纵杆，这个“画了一个圈又回到原点”的时刻其实并不那么令人惊奇，对吧？操纵杆是军方航空历史和发展的一部分。对他们来说并不新鲜。在过去的几十年里，操纵杆已经证明了自己是首选的人机接口。它一直在变得更好。对于远程操作技术的精细、精确控制来说，没有比操纵杆更直观、更优化的系统了。
The game companies did the job for them. Now, when it comes to the joystick specifically, This full-circle moment is not all that surprising, right? The joystick is part of the military's aviation history and development. It's not new to them. The joystick has kind of proven itself over the last several decades as the man-machine interface of choice. It's just kept getting better. There is no more intuitive, optimized system for delicate, precise control of remotely operated technology.
现在，“远程”这个词在这里很重要，因为当我们使用操纵杆在游戏世界中穿行时，我们知道屏幕上的那些世界并不是真的。而当士兵使用游戏手柄在屏幕上击落直升机时，那是真实且致命的。
than the joystick. Now the word remotely is important here because when we're using joysticks to navigate through game worlds, we know those worlds on our screen aren't real. When a soldier is using a video game controller to shoot down a helicopter on a screen, it is real and deadly.
我们设计了一种让执行极其重大的任务变得前所未有简单的事物。话又说回来，这些重大的任务也可以是拯救生命的。去年，在瑞士，有人通过PlayStation远程操作，在远在数千英里外香港的一只活猪身上实施了内窥镜手术。游戏手柄在医学领域的应用势头正在增强。今年早些时候，美国食品药品监督管理局（FDA）批准了Monarch支气管镜系统的最新版本，该系统使用直接改编自Xbox的手柄来操纵一根细小的管子穿过病人的肺部以发现和治疗疾病。这太不可思议了。Xbox风格的黑白设计、双把手形状、处于熟悉的对角线方向的两个拇指摇杆。
We've designed something that makes it easier than ever to execute incredibly consequential tasks. Then again, these consequential tasks can also be life-saving. Last year, an endoscopy was performed on a live pig in Hong Kong from thousands of miles away in Switzerland using a PlayStation. And momentum behind game controllers in medicine is building. Earlier this year, the FDA approved the latest iteration of the Monarch
同样优化的接口，从游戏室到作战室再到手术室。你如何看待游戏手柄被重新用于这类事情？
Broncoscopy system, which uses a controller adapted directly from the Xbox to maneuver a tiny tube through a patient's lungs to find and treat diseases. It is uncanny. The Xbox-esque black-and-white design, the two-handle shape, the two thumbsticks in that familiar diagonal orientation. The same optimized interface, from the game room to the war room to the operating room. How do you feel about game controllers being repurposed for things like this?
嗯，当极客获胜时，我总是很高兴。米科·希宁（Miko Hinen）是芬兰坦佩雷芬兰游戏博物馆（Finnish Museum of Games）的创始人，也是其2023年展览“The Joy of Sticks”幕后团队的一半。它展出了来自米科个人收藏的数百个游戏操纵杆，同时也追溯了该接口在社会中的重要性，从航空到医学。像这样的例子表明，游戏一直以来并且在很大程度上都是相通的。这是展览的另一半，尼古拉斯·纽兰（Nicholas Newland），博物馆的策展人之一。
Well, I'm always happy when the geeks win. Miko Hinen is the creator of the Finnish Museum of Games in Tumpur, Finland, and one half of the team behind its 2023 exhibition, The Joy of Sticks. It featured hundreds of gaming joysticks from Miko's personal collection, but also traced the interface's significance in society, from aviation to medicine. Examples like this show that games have always been and are very much connected. This is the exhibit's other half, Nicholas Newland, one of the museum's curators.
尽管这些芬兰人在操纵杆中找到了快乐，但米科和尼古拉斯确实勉强承认，下一个重大接口已经在这里了。如今，每个人都在所有事情上使用触控屏。哦，天哪，触控屏。它无处不在，但它很大并不意味着它更好。事实上，让操纵杆成为伟大接口的原因，正是让触控屏基本上成为一个黑盒子的原因。这种感知可供性的概念，你看着一个操纵杆，你就知道如何使用它。
Despite the joy these fins find in sticks, Miko and Nicholas do acknowledge, begrudgingly, that the next big interface is already here. Nowadays, everybody is using the touchscreen for everything. Oh boy, the touchscreen. It is ubiquitous, but just because it's big doesn't mean it's better. In fact, what makes the joystick great as an interface is the same thing that makes the touchscreen basically a black box. This idea of perceived affordance, you look at a joystick, you know how to use it.
它是一个直观的硬件。你看着一个触控屏，它只是一块平坦的玻璃。零感知可供性，完全受制于它的软件。所以触控屏赋予我们的，实际上只允许软件开发人员让我们用它做的事情。而尼古拉斯对此并不是特别高兴。触控屏可怕地单一，它们在某种程度上变得像是——我想，就像现代大型科技公司影响力的一种隐喻。一切都被塞进同一种接口中。而同一种接口正用无穷无尽的潜在用途、应用、地图、游戏轰炸我们，每一种都有其独特的使用触控屏的方式，你必须去适应它们。
It's an intuitive piece of hardware. You look at a touchscreen, and it's a flat piece of glass. Zero perceived affordance completely beholden to its software. And so what the touchscreen affords us is really only what the software developers want us to be able to do with it. And Nicholas isn't particularly happy about it. Touchscreens are scarily monolithic, and they sort of become like, I guess, like a metaphor for the influence of the big tech companies nowadays. Everything is put into the same type of interface. And that same interface is bombarding us with endless possible uses, apps, maps, games, that each have their own way of using the touchscreen that you have to get.
这是一个直观的硬件。你看着触摸屏，它就是一块平整的玻璃。毫无直观的可用性线索，完全受制于它的软件。因此，触摸屏提供给我们的，实际上只有软件开发人员希望我们用它做的事情。尼古拉斯对此并不是特别高兴。触摸屏具有可怕的整体性，它们在某种程度上变得像是当今大型科技公司影响力的隐喻。一切都被塞进同一种类型的界面中。而这个界面正用无数可能的用途、应用程序、地图、游戏轰炸着我们，每种用途都有你必须学会的使用触摸屏的独特方式。
Get used to. From swiping through potential soulmates, oof, not much joy in that, to signing your name with your fingertip. And we all know how well that usually turns out. On a touchscreen, you can do a lot of things, but like being very precise is not one of them. No, it is not, Miko. But convenience, versatility. Those are perhaps the touchscreen's primary affordances. one interface in our pockets all the time that allows us to communicate, shop, split a bill with friends, and crush all the candy.
习惯就好。从在潜在的灵魂伴侣中左右滑动（哦，这实在没什么乐趣），到用指尖签名。我们都知道那通常会变成什么样。在触摸屏上，你可以做很多事情，但要说非常精确，那可真做不到。确实如此，米科。但便利性和多功能性，或许正是触摸屏的主要特性。口袋里随时装着这样一个界面，能让我们交流、购物、和朋友 AA 制账单，还能玩个痛快。
But touchscreens have also made life literally flatter. Think of how many dials and buttons we've squashed into extinction. On our phones, our cash registers, in our cars. We're losing our grand. grip on the world. One swipe, scroll, and tap at a time. But the joystick... It's very different because you actually use your body when controlling. It offers us a physical human-machine connection, Niklaus says. The tactile, empowering experience of maneuvering an actual object to explore 3D space in a self-controlled way. Whether we're
但触摸屏也让生活变得彻底“扁平化”了。想想看，有多少旋钮和按键被我们无情地淘汰了。无论是手机上、收银机里，还是汽车里。我们对世界的掌控力正在一点点流失。每一次滑动、滚动和轻击都在加速这一点。然而，操纵杆却截然不同，因为你在控制时真正动用了身体。尼克劳斯说，它为我们提供了一种身体与机器之间的物理连接。那种通过操控实物来在三维空间中进行自我控制探索的触觉体验、赋能体验，无论是
flying a plane or driving Mario's cart. Poorly, in my case. It's our bodily affordances and machine affordances coming together in joyful, sometimes exhilarating harmony. You kind of become one with the joystick. And I think that's something that stays in people's muscle memory or bodily memory. like we want to be able to be very precise or we want to be able to sort of use our bodies for controlling. And sort of joysticks maybe remind us of this, that there's options. The breadth of different ways is good for us.
开飞机还是开马里奥赛车。就我而言，开得很烂。这是我们的身体机能与机器机能交织在一起，形成了一种令人愉悦、有时甚至振奋的和谐。你某种程度上与操纵杆合二为一了。我认为这种感觉会留在人们的肌肉记忆或身体记忆里。比如，我们希望能够非常精准，或者我们希望能够用身体来进行控制。操纵杆或许在提醒我们：我们还有别的选择。丰富多样的方式对我们是有益的。
You know, I too think maintaining a physical connection to our physical world with a physical interface like the joystick is good for us. Just like it's good to use our own software and hardware. our brains and bodies, and to be able to move those heads and bodies separately. So it's not really about one interface replacing another, or it shouldn't be. It's about having the tool that affords what you need. Versatility, specificity, convenience, precision. It all depends on the game. So, Amory on the right, those orange things make you go faster.
你知道，我也认为通过像操纵杆这样的物理界面与我们现实的物理世界保持物理连接，对我们是有益的。正如充分利用我们自身的软件和硬件——大脑和身体，并能够让头部和身体分别活动一样。所以，这其实并不是关于一个界面取代另一个界面，或者说它本不该如此。关键在于拥有能够满足你需求的工具。多功能性、专一性、便利性、精准性。这一切都取决于游戏。好了，右边的阿莫里，那些橘色的东西能让你加速。
Yes. Oh. It's kind of propelling arrows. You guys were setting me up for failure. We've been competing. Hooray! Ludwig. 12th.
好的。哦。这有点像推进箭头。你们俩合伙给我挖坑。我们一直在比赛。太棒了！路德维格。第 12 名。
12th of 12. I love that story. But I have one bone to pick with Amory Severson. because I'm here to tell you that the Atari 2,600 joystick is a beautiful piece of design, that you're like weak-risted millennials get tired using it. Yeah. That is your problem. That is not an Atari 2600's problem.
12 名里的第 12 名。我很喜欢这个故事。但我对阿莫里·西弗森有点小意见，因为我要告诉你们，雅达利 2600 的操纵杆绝对是一件精美的设计，那些手腕娇弱的 90 后嫌用它累。没错。那是你们的问题。这可不是雅达利 2600 的问题。
To say nothing of the rich mahogany veneer on the outside of this thing, it really is a beautiful piece of machinery. The machine is gorgeous. You could throw it down three flights of stairs. You could fry an egg on it, and it'll still play. That thing is a gorgeous piece of the pinnacle of design. And so, like, when she goes to that, she's like, I don't like it. Like, what the hell is going on there? But anyway, I'll let her have her say.
更不用说这东西外表还镶嵌着华丽的红木贴面，它确实是一件精美的机械艺术品。这机器太棒了。你把它从三层楼梯上扔下去，或者在上面煎个鸡蛋，它照样能玩。那东西简直是一件华丽的巅峰之作。所以当她看到这个时，却说她不喜欢。这到底是怎么回事？不过没关系，我让她自己说。
She is a great reporter. So, Roman, your letters and everybody else's letters about Amory's thoughts on the Atari 2,600. I'll happily bring them directly to her. Forward to her, because I will not have any of this Atari slander in my house. But of course, Amory talked about some much more serious. stuff that we're going to pick up in our next episode, and that is military applications for video game technology. For episode three of Hidden Levels, we're going to tell you how the U.S. military uses video games to recruit. So, you're probably wondering to yourself,
她是一位优秀的记者。所以，罗曼，关于阿莫里对雅达利 2600 的看法的来信，以及大家的来信，我会很乐意直接转交给他。转交给她，因为我绝不允许在我的家里出现任何诋毁雅达利言论。当然，阿莫里还谈到了一些更为严肃的话题，我们将在下一集中探讨，那就是电子游戏技术的军事应用。在《隐藏关卡》第三集里，我们将告诉你美国军方是如何利用电子游戏来招募新兵的。所以，你大概会纳闷：
the U.S. Army has an e-sports program? Why? And how do I join? The U.S. Army ESports program is a recruiting outreach tool to help the Army connect with the fast-growing e-sports audience. That is the next time on hidden levels from 99% invisible and endless thread. This episode was produced by Amory Sievertson. It was edited by Meg Kramer. Mix and sound design by Emily Jenkowski. Additional mixing by Martine Gonzalez, music composition by Paul Vikas,
美军怎么会有电子竞技项目？为什么？我又该如何加入？美军电子竞技项目是一项招募拓展工具，旨在帮助军队与快速增长的电子竞技受众建立联系。以上是“99% Invisible”和“Endless Thread”联合制作的《隐藏关卡》下期预告。本集由阿莫里·西弗森制作。由梅格·克雷默剪辑。混音和声音设计由艾米莉·詹科夫斯基负责。附加混音由马丁·冈萨雷斯完成，音乐创作由保罗·维卡斯操刀，
series theme by Swan Rayal and Paul Vikas. Fact-checking by Laura Bullens. Special thanks to Amory's Mario Kart opponents, Philip Sousy, Kelly O'Connell, and Mike Mosquito, and to Henry Lowood for sharing his expertise and tipping Amory off to The Joy of Sticks Exhibition. 99% Invisible as executive producer is Kathy Too. Kurt Kolstad is our digital director, Delaney Hall is our senior editor.
系列主题曲由斯旺·拉亚尔和保罗·维卡斯创作。事实核查由劳拉·布伦斯完成。特别感谢阿莫里的马里奥赛车对手菲利普·苏西、凯利·奥康奈尔和迈克·莫斯基托，以及感谢亨利·洛伍德分享他的专业知识并向阿莫里透露了“操纵杆的乐趣”展览的消息。“99% Invisible”的执行制片人是凯茜·图。库尔特·科尔斯塔德是我们的数字总监，德兰尼·霍尔是我们的资深编辑。
The rest of the team includes Jason DeLeon, Emmett Fitzgerald, Christopher Johnson, Vivian Lay, Lashamadon, Jacob Medina Gleason, Kelly Prime, Joe Rosenberg, and me, Roman Mars. The 99% Visible logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. The art for this series was created by Aaron Nestor. We are part of the Series XM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north, in the Pandora building in beautiful, uptown, Oakland, California. Endless Thread is a production of WBUR, Boston's NPR. The rest of our team tackling unsolved mysteries, untold histories, and other wild stories from the internet includes managing producer Sumit to Joshi, production manager, Paul Bikis, producers Dean Russell, Grace Tatter, and Franny Monaghan.
团队的其他成员包括杰森·德莱昂、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、维维安·莱、拉沙马多、雅各布·梅迪纳·格利森、凯利·普赖姆、乔·罗森伯格，以及我——罗曼·马尔斯。“99% Visible”的标志由斯特凡·劳伦斯设计。本系列的艺术作品由亚伦·内斯特创作。我们是 SiriusXM 播客家族的一员，总部现已迁往加利福尼亚州奥克兰市繁华的上城区潘多拉大厦以北六个街区。《Endless Thread》是波士顿 NPR 电台 WBUR 的制作节目。我们团队的其他成员致力于攻克未解之谜、鲜为人知的历史以及来自互联网的其他疯狂故事，包括总制作人苏米特·托·乔希、制作经理保罗·比基斯、制作人迪恩·拉塞尔、格蕾丝·塔特和弗兰尼·莫纳汉。
We'll see you for a new episode of Hidden Levels on Tuesday. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们周二见，届时将播出《隐藏关卡》的新一集。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。